David Donald Trump is increasingly
talking about giving businesses immunity
from coronavirus related lawsuits does
this make sense or should employees
always be able to sue sue and seek
damages from their employer if they were
to catch coronavirus as a result of
being back at work listen this is really
a complicated issue from a practicum a
logistical sense from a legal sense
where you have to understand well what
is the current liability that employers
have is catching coronavirus the same as
an unsafe warehouse where you get run
over by a forklift because the forklift
didn't make the beeping noise and have
the red light that it's supposed to have
and steel toed shoes weren't require
right these are these are very different
questions when it comes to something
like coronavirus if you go to work and
you catch coronavirus and everybody was
behaving safely and the employer has
opened in accordance with CDC guidelines
foreign state guidelines for okay
employees need masks and the employees
had masks there should be X number of
sanitation's they if all the rules are
being adhered to and people catch
coronavirus it's very difficult to say
that the employer should be liable for
that particularly when the contagion may
have happened because of some random
customer or who knows it's a very
difficult legal question but should
there be some blanket immunity for
employers of course not of course not
we have an infrastructure for
determining when an employer is or is
not liable for something that happens to
an employee or to a customer on the
premises it is very robust legislation
it is very established there is no
shortage of cases of all kinds about
employers who failed to protect
employees and customers or who were sued
but it was determined they actually did
take the proper precaution
the danger here is that for political
reasons and for the purposes of
furthering what has become a culture war
over coronavirus Donald Trump is seeking
to give blanket immunity for anything
coronavirus related that happens in
their place of business when they reopen
and what this is really about is
employers who are not following the
guidelines that Trump wants to see have
immunity so that they will just open up
even when it is not yet safe to do so on
the basis of the guidelines that have
been put in place this is about Trump
wanting to give a carte blanche sort of
situation to employers that want to
reopen and even though the state says
you need masks they don't want their
employees to wear masks and in some
cases may even tell their employees no
masks whatsoever so for me the last
thing we need is any blanket immunity
for employers but I am sensitive to the
reality that your employer can be doing
the right thing and you might get
coronavirus versus your employer might
not be doing the right thing those are
the situations that need to be
adjudicated listen here's the reality if
you're an essential worker at a grocery
store and you continue working we know
that the longer you are in places where
the virus is circulating your odds of
contracting it go way way up spending 15
minutes with a mask on at Trader Joe's
even if there are people in there with
the virus is not hugely likely to end up
with you getting the virus spending
eight hours a day five or six days a
week there even with a mask dramatically
still sees an increase in the chance
that you get it does that mean the
employer is acting inappropriately and
should be sued no not necessarily what I
do think is that essential workers
should be compensated additionally for
the fact that they are essential and are
often some of the least well-paid people
that's a battle I'll have all day long
but if employers really are being safe
we have a system that would adjudicate
that and would say this lawsuit has no
merit the employer did the right thing
everybody did the right thing
we have a contagious situation if
grocery stores should have been closed
that's a bigger governmental call that
should have been made but we don't need
any special dispensation as the case may
be from Donald Trump for the federal
government to shield a priori employers
because employers may take advantage of
that and some will take advantage of it
to have deliberately unsafe conditions
that they believe are better for them in
the short and maybe medium term you
could say listen over the long term if
all your employees get sick and a bunch
of them die it's bad for PR you're not
going to have employees okay there are
lots of industries that have such
turnover as it is that they regularly
have a stable of applicants and they can
bring people in quickly and train them
relatively quickly for relatively
unskilled labor many businesses would
not really be concerned about that so no
blanket immunity we have a system that
can determine is this a valid claim or
is this what we would call a frivolous
claim they don't need any special
bailout it's part of the culture war
it's part of this haphazard desire to
open the economy fully immediately
regardless of the what the repercussions
are in my experience any blanket
immunities for corporations from future
lawsuits are bad news I am open to the
idea that sometimes they are okay I
looked today for examples couldn't find
any couldn't find any if you have an
example absolutely let me know we have a
great bonus show for you today I hope
you will be there get a membership at
join pakman.com to get instant access
and remember you can sign up for free
for the daily audio podcast of the show
a lot of people don't know there's a
daily hour-long podcast it's on iTunes
it's on stitcher you can find the feed
link on our website it's available make
sure you're signed up for that Pat's got
the bonus show today I'll be back on
Monday if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just
fifteen minutes and you get all of the
important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video